la masturbation permettrait d'avoir un
plus haut poste et un meilleur oui il
s'agit d'un sondage américain relayés
par nos experts qu'ils savent aller
personne qui se masturbe régulièrement
serait plus détendu aurait plus
confiance en elle et accéderaient plus
facilement à des postes à responsabilité
bon ben on apprend tous les jours
maintenant vous savez ce qui vous reste
à faire si vous voulez avoir une
augmentation
moi je vous laisse je vais de ce pas
reprendre ma carrière en main ou pas
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cet
épisode hors série où je vais faire
quelque chose que j'ai pas vraiment
l'habitude de faire c'est à dire que
j'ai revenir sur une information qui a
pas mal circulé dans les médias
je ne sais pas si vous l'aviez vu passer
c'était aux alentours du mois de
septembre et depuis je l'avais gardé
dans un coin de ma tête en disant que ça
ferait un bon une bonne porte d'entrée
pour faire un épisode plus axé pensée
critique méthodologie et comme le
confinement me laisse un peu plus de
temps que d'habitude j'en profite pour
me fendre d'un petit tuto sur comment ne
pas se laisser abuser par ces fameuses
et sud américaines qui sont si souvent
reprise dans nos médias parce
qu'évidemment dans ce type de format
c'est très facile de passer du côté
obscur de la force et de s'insurger
bêtement sur un homme de paille
je précise quand même que les
journalistes qui ont relayé
l'information ont fait preuve de
prudence sur les capacités scientifiques
des résultats étude assez bancale d'un
point de vue scientifique voire un bang
balante mais qui a eu le mérite de faire
sourire les internautes et ils font bien
d'être prudent pour simplifier
voici un graphique qui vous présente la
probabilité que le résultat soit
scientifiquement validées donc là vous
avez en rouge
aucune chance et forcément le reste 1
c'est pas toujours aucune chance mais en
bleu parce que vous allez voir cette
enquête c'est du total bullshit
alors saisissez vous de votre
lubrifiants et de votre gel
hydroalcoolique en prenant bien soin de
ne pas les confondre
et on est parti
[Musique]
reprenons des filles et on va commencer
par regarder comment a été relayé
l'information dans plusieurs sources
pour voir si l'extrait vidéo est
représentatif de la façon dont a été
relayé l'information en france ou si
déjà on a affaire à une simplification
je me suis arrêté à la première page de
google parce que il faut bien définir
une limite et j'ai trouvé une neuf
articles en ligne qui disent à peu près
la même chose
il s'étale entre le 27 et le 14 octobre
2019 donc déjà on peut remarquer que
c'est une information qui a été relayée
de façon assez courtes dans le temps qui
a plutôt fait un buzz avant d'être
rapidement oublié sur la façon de
relayer l'information on peut déjà
s'intéresser au titre des articles qui
font preuve de plus ou moins de prudence
sur les neuf articles 6 se contentent
dans leurs titres d'exposer les
résultats à savoir une corrélation entre
le fait de se pignoler et le niveau de
salaire et c'est plutôt avec les trois
derniers xv a commencé à se gâter
donc pour les titres prudent on a ceux
qui se touchent régulièrement sont plus
riches selon un sondage sexe les gens
qui se caressent souvent ont plus de
chances d'être manager les salariés qui
se font plaisir aurait plus de chances
de devenir manager les personnes qui
s'auto érotise souvent réussissent mieux
au travail
d'après une étude les gens qui se
paluche beaucoup ont plus de chances de
devenir manager et de gagner plus
insolite le saviez vous une étude montre
que ceux qui se taquinent gagnent plus
que les autres par contre les trois
derniers articles ne prennent pas
vraiment pas un set et annonce dès le
début qu'il ya une relation de causalité
c'est à dire que c'est le fait de se
relire le bibelot qui cause
l'augmentation du salaire
le premier site c'est marie france qui
conserve encore quelques pincettes
puisque le titre est sous forme
interrogative branlette et réussite
professionnelle quel rapport n'est qu
est immédiatement suivi par vous
souhaitez réussir professionnellement on
a peut-être la solution pour vous la
poune yade on vous explique tout
après on a le site met dix sites qui
plonge à pieds joints dans l'explication
causal avec un titre
on ne peut plus explicite ce faire
gicler permet d'avoir en plus hauts
postes et un meilleur salaire est le
grand gagnant dans la catégorie foutage
de gueule c'est l'article sur lequel se
basent directement la vidéo
d'introduction qui est un article de
yahoo qui nous
si le chatouille age ii pédoncule
permettrait d'avoir un plus haut poste
et un meilleur salaire
c'est la science qui le dit je crois
qu'on tient notre grand gagnant du titre
put à cliquer et non le conditionnel ne
suffit pas à rendre le truc hockey
surtout quand on essaye de rentrer le
truc avec un coût de 6 est la science
qui le dit cela dit même si certains
sont plus prudents que d'autres dans
leurs titres on retrouve exactement la
même information dans chacun des
articles
d'après une étude unis via réalisé sur
1012 personnes
ceux qui se font jouir régulièrement ont
un salaire moyen de 47000 76 dollars
contre 44 milles 6 $ pour ceux qui font
ça plus rarement
autre donnée largement partagé les hyper
active de la libido sont plus nombreux à
avoir demandé une augmentation dans
l'année 22 6 % contre 15 % pour les
autres et jusque là j'ai aucun problème
avec ça on ne fait que relever une
corrélation entre des variables et
beaucoup de choses pourraient expliquer
ça
le problème c'est qu'il ne s'arrête pas
là et pour expliquer le phénomène il
convoque tous la même raison qui semble
donc venir de l'étude originale à savoir
que le fait de se faire un petit 5
contre 1 ça permet aux individus d'être
plus détendu et donc de davantage osé
demander une augmentation à leur bosse
et que c'est pour ça qu'ils ont un
salaire plus élevé autrement dit on
bascule dans l'explication causale
et c'est là qu'il me perdre complètement
je vais revenir là dessus dans un
instant avant de passer à la suite je
souligne quand même qu'il y à certains
articles qui ont senti que ça puis un
peu du cul comme analyse et qui ont
pointé la limite principale qui semble
quand même assez évidente donc dans
trois de ses huit articles on nous
présente quand même que toutefois le
groupe des amateurs de nanisme comporte
plus d'hommes qui jouent aux solitaires
13 fois par mois en moyenne contre 6
fois pour les femmes ce qui peut
expliquer les plus gros salaires liés
aux postes à responsabilité
malheureusement plus fréquent chez les
hommes
non je pense que ça peut jouer genre
vraiment le sexe serait une variable
pertinente quand on parle de pratiques
sexuelles
si vous montre un peu cynique comme ça
c'est que j'ai même pas besoin de faire
une étude pour penser qu' a priori s'il
ya des écarts entre les salaires des
gros et des petits leaders de bright a
priori ça s'explique davantage par les
écarts de salaires hommes femmes que par
les faits supposés du championnat bureau
génitales sur les salaires
et même les trois articles qui mentionne
cette limite ils le font juste au détour
d'un petit toutefois comme je viens de
vous lire mais ils remettent pas du tout
en cause l'explication causal du mia qui
vient de ce seuil et qui du coup est
plus détendue et aux plus facilement
demander une augmentation à son boss et
pour les autres articles
alors c'est carrément le festival avec
des petites phrases du jard bref vous
l'aurez compris se battre les couilles
en neige aide à réussir au travail ou
encore bon et ben à vous de vous prendre
en main ou alors le magnifique
bref vous l'aurez compris pour lier
l'utile avoir une promotion une
augmentation à l'agréable
pensez à vous défrise et la chicorée
régulièrement il ya pire comme activité
no cry brise no no no no là on vient
surtout de voir la façon de travailler
des journalistes mais leur boulot ça
devrait être justement de pointer les
limites pas de se contenter de répéter
bêtement ce que dit une enquête tout
pourri mais de montrer en quoi leur
conclusion ça ressemble à un gros caca
fumant mais bon avant d'aller puiser
l'information à la source primordiale et
d'aller voir cette fameuse enquête de
laquelle tout est parti faisons un petit
point pour vous expliquer en quoi c'est
grave de confondre une simple
corrélation avec une causalité est
pourquoi les journalistes qui veulent
relayer ce genre d'étude là il devrait
être particulièrement formés à ce type
de questions bon allez vous venez on y
va ok c'est bon ça va
ok donc on est parti pour un petit topo
rapide sur la distinction entre
corrélation et causalité une corrélation
ça désigne simplement le fait que deux
variables évolué de façon conjointe
la corrélation est positive si les deux
variables évoluent dans le même sens et
elle est négative
si les deux variables évoluent en sens
inverse dans cette étude ce qu'on voit
c'est que quand la fréquence des
feuillages de baobab augmente le salaire
moyen augmente on a bien une relation
positive mais ce qu'il faut bien garder
en tête c'est que c'est pas très
difficile d'avoir une corrélation entre
deux variables suis d'avoir deux courbes
qui se ressemble à peu près enfin ça
fait une corrélation quoi la preuve en
images en rouge
vous avez la quantité de fromage
consommés par personne aux états unis
et en noir vous avez le nombre de
personnes qui meurent chaque année et
tout fait dans leurs draps et je vous
assure qu'il ya une réelle corrélation
entre ces deux variables
regardez comme les cours de ce suisse
bien on a un coefficient de corrélation
d'à-peu-près 0,95 quand on sait que le
maximum c'est un ça commence à faire de
la belle corrélation par contre peut-on
conclure qu'il ya une causalité entre
ces variables
bien évidemment non une relation de
causalité ça voudrait dire qu'il y à
l'une des variables qui est la cause de
l'autre par exemple que c'est parce que
les gens dansent plus de fromage que il
s'étrangle plus en leurs draps on voit
bien que ça n'a pas de sens à moins que
les mecs ils mangent du fromage dans
leur lit du coup ça fait les miettes et
ils secouent leurs draps pour enlever
les miettes et du coup ça augmente leur
chance de s'enfuir ou non je sais en
fait c'est leur femme qui supporte plus
d'avoir la bouffe dans lui et qui
finissent par les étouffer et qui
maquille ça pour un accident
je crois qu'on tient un truc l'un comme
vous voyez on a tout de suite tendance à
essayer de chercher des explications
causale et c'est pas de notre faute on
est câblé comme ça notre cerveau est
fait pour trouver des relations de
causalité et à sa décharge 95% du temps
ça fonctionne très bien pour plus de
détails sur comment fonctionnent ces
différents biais je vous renvoie à la
chaîne youtube la tronche en biais qui
explique très bien toutes ces petites
fantaisies de notre cerveau mais pour en
revenir à nos moutons vous avez compris
où je veux en venir il faut être très
prudent avec la corrélation parce que la
corrélation n'implique pas à la
causalité est ce que je déclenche saint
bonnet vulgarisateur pour avoir prononcé
cette phrase non pour simplifier il y a
trois choses qui peuvent expliquer une
corrélation
premièrement la causalité oui c'est pas
parce que c'est pas toujours vrai que
c'est jamais vrai des fois on a bien les
deux corrélation et causalité
par exemple un plus il y a de pluie plus
il y a deux parapluies chez les gens qui
marchent dans la rue
enfin pour parler d'une époque où on
pouvait encore marcher dans la rue on a
bien une corrélation entre ces deux
variables et c'est aussi une causalité
puisque c'est la pluie qui cause
l'augmentation des parapluies et on voit
bien que la causalité elle a un sens
aussi parce que l'un vers ce n'est pas
vrai on ne peut pas dire que
l'augmentation des parapluies cause la
pluie bon là j'ai pris un exemple mes
gars simple évidemment des fois c'est un
peu plus compliqué il ya des effets
rétroactifs de causalité avec des
variables qui s'influencent mutuellement
par exemple
le niveau de revenus augmentent le
niveau de patrimoine qui augmente
lui-même le niveau de revenu qui va ré
augmenter le niveau de patrimoine etc
ça fait une boucle de causalité mais
restons simples pour le moment deuxième
explication pour une corrélation la
variable cacher qu'on appelle aussi le
facteur de confusion
ça c'est le truc le plus important à
vérifier si on veut pas passer pour un
glandu en criant trop vite à la
causalité vérifier que mes deux
variables ne sont pas corrélées tout
simplement parce qu'elles sont toutes
les deux causée par une troisième
variable par exemple quand la
consommation de glaces augmente le
nombre de morts par noyade augmentent
également
s'il vraie corrélation très solide qui
se vérifie très fortement
est ce que ça veut dire que manger des
glaces augmente vos chances de vous
noyer
pas du tout elles sont toutes les deux
imposées par une troisième variable la
température quand il fait chaud je mange
plus de glace mais je vais aussi plus me
baigner ce qui augmente mes chances de
mourir par noyade corrélation n'est pas
causalité et cet exemple là je les fais
avec des élèves
ils ont été nombreux à essayer de me
trouver une explication causal du type
oui alors si un enfant il a assisté à
une mort par noyade du coup bas ses
parents ils vont plus lui payer des
glaces pour le consoler non non c'est
juste une variable cacher il n'ya pas à
chercher plus loin et troisième
explication le hasard ça arrive que deux
variables soit corrélé alors qu'il n'ya
aucune relation d'aucune sorte entre
elles mais si vous allez faire un tour
sur le site space kovalainen vous
pourrez en voir des dizaines du même
type que celle que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure par exemple plus il ya
deux lancements spatiaux non commerciaux
plus il ya de doctorat de sociologie
accordée aux états unis ou en allemagne
plus il ya de films documentaires
produits sur le territoire plus le
nombre de cochon a battu augmente
forcément avec les dizaines de milliers
de données pour collecte partout il est
fort c'est que des corrélations
hasardeuse apparaissent c'est là où le
travail d'un scientifique c'est de
s'assurer que la corrélation qu'il est
en train d'observer n'est ni causé par
le hasard ni causé par une variables
cachées et alors là et seulement là on
peut commencer à émettre l'hypothèse
d'une causalité
mais pour mettre en évidence une
causalité en fait il faut réunir bien
d'autres informations que la corrélation
dans l'exemple que j'ai fait sur la
causalité j'ai dit on à une corrélation
entre la quantité de pluie et le nombre
de parapluies pourtant qu'est ce qui me
permet
de conclure que c'est une causalité si
j'étais un extraterrestre qui n'a aucune
idée de comment fonctionne la planète
terre il n'est pas sûr que j'en arrive à
ces conclusions là parce que en termes
de données apparemment j'ai exactement
la même chose que pour les autres c'est
à dire une corrélation positive
alors qu'est ce qui me permet à moi de
conclure à la causalité ici là en fait
plein de choses
si j'étais d'expliciter un petit peu le
raisonnement qui m'a amené à conclure à
une causalité en fait j'ai pris plein
d'éléments en comptant plus de la
corrélation quantités de pluie non de
parapluies déjà je sais que c'est
précisément pour se protéger de la pluie
qu'ont été créés les parapluies donc
c'est assez logique qu'on les sorte
quand il pleut en plus et j'ai une
expérience du sujet je me suis déjà
retrouvé avec les cheveux mouillés parce
que j'étais sorti sous la pluie sans
parapluie donc à une cohérence logique à
la chose ensuite il ya une question de
temporalité et de permanence de l'effet
aussi je m'aperçois que régulièrement
quand il pleut les gens sortent les
parapluies par contre j'ai déjà observée
de la pluie alors qu'il avait pas de
parapluie donc visiblement ce n'est pas
les parapluies qui cause la pluie mais
plutôt l'arrière ce bref je vais arrêter
là pour cet exemple mais vous voyez
l'idée que pour conclure à une causalité
je prends en compte en fait tout une
galette et d'informations qui vont bien
au-delà de la simple corrélation mais si
ces éléments sont assez évident quand on
prend des exemples simples
il va falloir être un peu plus prudent
dès qu'on a affaire à un cas un peu plus
complexes comme le cas qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
mais reprenons justement ce que l'on
sait pour le moment de notre exemple on
sait qu'il ya une corrélation entre le
niveau de salaire et le fait de faire
sourire le lutin et entre la probabilité
de demander une augmentation
et le fait de se caresser le vélo et
c'est tout le seul élément que les
articles se propose d'ajouter pour
transformer cette corrélation et
causalité
c'est une explication physiologique au
psychologique du genre ça permet d'être
plus détendu et donc davantage osé
demander une hausse de salaire moi je
veux bien y'a pas de problème mais ça
fait quand même un peu léger comme
hypothèse parce que si le critère
principal pour avoir une augmentation
c'est d'être détendu pourquoi on fait
pas une étude sur l'effet du massage des
pieds sur les salaires aussi ça aussi ça
permet d'être détendu et surtout même en
imaginant qu'on ait une relation causale
entre ces deux variables je montrerai
plus tard que je pense que c'est pas du
tout le cas mes expériences de pensée
imaginons et il ya bien une relation de
causalité entre ces variables
qu'est ce qui nous permet de connaître
le sens de cette cause
lité pourquoi est ce que ce serait la
variable graissage de salami qui causent
la variable salaires est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas imaginer que ce soit la
variable salaires qui causent la
variable changer l'eau aux olives et je
pourrais vous trouver une explication
physiologique au psychologique tout à
fait aussi convaincante que la leur pour
soutenir mon hypothèse
regardez je vous le fais les personnes
qui ont un haut revenu ce sont des
managers des responsables qui ont un
métier stressant et du coup ils ont
aussi beaucoup plus besoin de relâcher
la pression que les autres
c'est pour ça que les managers ayant un
revenu bien métier plus stressant vont
beaucoup plus souvent que les autres
peigner la girafe
on voit bien que c'est donc bien la
variable salaires qui causent la
variable s'alourdir à petit feu non ça
en fait c'est une idée reçue
vous voyez ce que je veux faire la j12
complètement retourné la causalité et on
a à peu près au même degré de
vraisemblance que l'étude précédemment
cités donc ça ça doit être un gros
indice comme quoi leur justification au
mieux elle manque de robustesse et ou
pire ben c'est de la merde mais
justement maintenant c'est le moment que
je me penche un peu plus sur cette
fameuse étude originale et vous allez
voir que ceux de la merde alors c'est
bien une étude qui a été faite sur 1012
personnes interrogées le problème c'est
qu'on nous dit pas du tout comment elles
ont été sélectionnés parce que c'est un
peu le nombre minimal de personnes à
partir duquel on peut commencer à dire
que les résultats veulent à peu près
dire quelque chose à condition seulement
que l'échantillon soit représentatif de
la population
mais bon on va leur laisser le bénéfice
du doute
bon il nous donne pas mal d'infos
général sur le groupe inge l'âge je vais
passer assez vite à 6 les tient la fun
fact on voit qu aux etats unis
ceux qui votent démocrate vont traire
l'anguille bien plus fréquemment que les
républicains
c'est important de souligner en passant
on voit deux infos que je vais relever
donc on nous montre quand même qu'il ya
une grosse différence dans la fréquence
de pistonnage entre les hommes et les
femmes où l'on voit qu'en moyenne les
femmes se font monter la marée six jours
par mois contre 13 pour les hommes on
voit la même différence dans des
tableaux qui récapitule les données pour
les hommes et les femmes selon les
différentes catégories d'âge
et après on en arrive au coeur du truc
les effets sur le travail et le salaire
alors d'abord on constate la différence
de salaire annuel 47000 72 dollars pour
ceux qui s'ils ratent fréquemment
l'entrejambes contre 44 milles 6 $ pour
ceux qui préfèrent rester au sec
ok donc c'est bien la même info qu'on a
déjà vu plusieurs fois et après on a une
série de quatre données temps plein ou
temps partiel ont une position de
manager ou non ont demandé une
augmentation ou non et ont obtenu une
augmentation ou non et pour toutes ces
catégories on constate que ceux qui
stastiques fréquemment le casque sont à
chaque fois mieux lotis que les autres
et après on en arrive à leurs
conclusions
une pépite donc je vous la présente tel
quel
l'amélioration de la confiance en soi
que la pignol a déjà montré provoqué
pourrait être un contributeur majeur à
un salaire plus élevé car il peut
falloir un certain degré de confiance en
soi et de courage pour oser demander une
augmentation à son patron et ceux qui
ceux des gorges fréquemment le poireau
en huit points de pourcentage de chances
en plus d'avoir ce qu'il faut pour oser
demander une augmentation
si on va un cran plus loin le lustrage
de bijoux pourrait-il influencer la
différence de salaires hommes femmes
si titiller fréquemment vos parties
augmente vos chances de demander une
augmentation et que les femmes ont moins
de chances d'aller souvent exploré la
caverne
la réponse semblerait être we were
vraiment là tellement énorme que je sais
pas quoi dire non parce que les mecs
voit clairement que leurs études
seule la merde enfin je veux dire ils
voient que visiblement le sexe est un
gros facteur de confusion mais ils font
semblant que tout va bien et du coup au
lieu de dire un truc du genre
peut-être que les différences de
salaires entre les deux groupes
s'explique davantage par les écarts de
salaires hommes femmes que par la
différence de fréquence avec laquelle il
envoie la purée et d'essayer de le
vérifier mais il te retourne
complètement le truc et ils s'en servent
pour te forcer leurs explications causal
à la mord moi le noeud
les mecs sont tellement persuadés que
et la tyrannie pompette qui causent les
différences de salaires que ce qu'ils
sont en train de nous dire en substance
c'est que c'est parce que les femmes
sont moins pleurer la madeleine qu'elles
gagnent moins que les hommes bon et bien
on va essayer de regarder à partir de ce
qu'on a comme donné on va essayer de
vérifier si le sexe est un facteur de
confusion
suffisant pour expliquer la totalité des
variations de salaires ou alors s'il
nous reste une partie de l'écart entre
les deux groupes inexpliqué qui que l'on
pourrait alors peut-être et je dis bien
peut-être attribué à le taux de
bricolage l'idée c'est qu'on va essayer
de quantifier
quelle part de la variation de salaires
entre les deux groupes est explicable
par la composition sexuelle des groupes
ou est attribuable à autre chose je vous
explique
pour arrondir on a à peu près 3000
dollars de différence entre les deux
groupes
et justement c'est ce qu'on veut essayer
d'expliquer sait d'où vient cette
différence donc 3000 $ c'est ma variable
a expliqué et je suis donc à la
recherche de variables explicatives
la première chose à voir c'est que les
deux groupes n'ont pas le même nombre
d'hommes et de femmes
donc plutôt que d'avoir un truc comme ça
on va plutôt avoir un truc comme ça et
on sait qu'en général dans nos sociétés
et en particulier aux etats-unis le
salaire graines des hommes est plus
élevé que le salaire que gagnent les
femmes donc toutes choses égales par
ailleurs si je fais deux groupes qui
n'ont pas la même composition sexuelle
et que j'attribue à chaque personne le
salaire moyen de son sexe il est fort
c'est qu'il y aura une différence de
salaire moyen entre ces deux groupes
et cette différence là ne pourra être
expliquée que par le sexe puis ce sera
le seul critère de différence qu'on aura
pris en compte et après ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'ordre de grandeur de
cette variation
parce que imaginons maintenant que la
différence de composition sexuelle des
groupes permettent d'expliquer une
variation de l'ordre de seulement deux
mille dollars
étant donné qu entre mes deux groupes
initiaux il avait une variation de 3000
$ alors ça voudrait dire que deux tiers
de mes variation s'explique par la
différence de composition sexuelle des
groupes mais ça voudrait aussi dire
qu'il resterait encore mille dollars
d'écarts soit un tiers de ma variations
qui ne serait pas expliquée par la
composition actuelle des groupes et du
coup peut-être éventuellement que cette
partie de la différence serait
explicable par le fait de jouer souvent
de la flûte à un trou mais avant
d'essayer de trouver une explication
on va déjà essayer de voir si elle
existe cette partie non expliqué de la
variation il faut faire les choses dans
l'ordre
donc la première étape pour essayer de
vérifier ça ce sera avant tout de
déterminer quelle est la composition
sexuelle des groupes entre ceux qui font
beaucoup mousser la créature et les
autres le problème c'est qu'évidemment
il ne donne pas leur donner en accès
libre donc je peux pas vérifier
directement je vais devoir bidouiller à
partir des informations qui lui donne
dans l'étude et faire un petit peu de
ritchot ingineering de la data bon le
premier problème c'est que j'ai aucune
idée de combien il ya d'hommes et comme
il ya de femmes dans les groupes de
tripoteur fréquents et de tripoteur peu
fréquents et les seules données dont
dispose ce sont ces tableaux où on me
donne la proportion de tripotage par
sexe mais aussi par classe d'âge du coup
ça en brouille encore plus le
schmilblick et j'ai ce graphe qui me
donne la fréquence de l'auto jouissance
totale
mais ici pour tous les échantillons
hommes et femmes confondus donc mal j'ai
pas le choix il faut que j'utilise ces
tableaux pour essayer de déduire la
composition de leurs échantillons
le problème c'est que je connais pas non
plus la composition en termes de classes
d'âge de leur échantillon mais comme je
leur accorde le bénéfice du doute je
vais considérer que leur échantillon est
représentatif de la population et je
vais chercher a extrapolé à partir de la
vraie répartition des âges que je
récupère sur le site du recensement
américain
j'ai modifié légèrement mais coefficient
pour coller à leurs données parce que
dans leurs échantillons il y a un peu
plus de femmes que dans la population
réelle
donc j'en arrive à quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce qu'ils ont avec 51 3% de
femmes pour 48 avec le 7 % d'hommes et
de jolis tableaux de correspondance donc
en partant de leurs tableaux pour les
hommes et pour les femmes et on le
comparant à la pyramide des âges dans la
population américaine
j'obtiens la composition d'un
échantillon total mixte et pour vérifier
que je suis pas complètement à côté de
la plaque
je vais comparer les données de mon
échantillon total avec celui de leur
échantillon total pour voir si ce à quoi
l'a peu près hélas la tuile je remarque
que ma composition d'échantillons ne
doit pas être la bonne parce que j'ai
presque cinq points d'écart avec leurs
données donc visiblement il ya une
couille dans le potage
cela dit c'est assez facile à corriger
parce que visibles
le mans il me manque des étrangleur
dedans dont fréquents et j'ai beaucoup
trop de mou de la libido par rapport à
leurs chiffres à eux étant donné que le
mode de recrutement de leurs
échantillons a été fait via internet et
surtout qu'ils ont fait dans leur
tableau une catégorie unique pour tous
les plus de 50 ans il me semble assez
évident que c'est parce que j'ai
beaucoup trop de vieux non mon
échantillon du coup je corrige mon
recrutement en enlevant toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans et la
magie je retombe sur quelque chose de
très proche de leur donner à eux
[Musique]
alors bien sûr c'est pas parfait mais ce
sera largement assez proche pour ce que
je veux faire ici et puis de toute façon
si on leur donne et je pourrai jamais
savoir exactement comment ils ont fait
leur recrutement du coup maintenant je
suis à peu près bon en termes de
proportion hommes femmes et deux
catégories d'âge donc maintenant je peux
rien j'ai quitté les données sur les
fréquences de paugnat paris mon groupe
de ceux qui jouent souvent de la
mandoline g 63 % d'hommes et 37 % de
femmes et dont on groupe de ceux qui
rendent rarement visite à madame cinq
doigts j'ai 25 % d'hommes pour 75 % de
femmes magnifiques donc maintenant
essayons de voir ce que cette
composition nous donne comme écarts de
salaires évidemment je ne connais pas
les salaires des véritables l'enquêté
puisque je n'ai toujours pas accès à
leurs données mais je faire une
approximation en utilisant les salaires
médians de chaque sexe le salaire médian
c'est le salaire défini tels que la
moitié de la population gagne en dessous
et la moitié de la population gagne au
dessus on préfère l'utiliser au salaire
moyen parce qu'il est plus stable et ne
se fait pas tiré vers le haut par les
très hauts revenus
j'ai donc regardé quel est le salaire
médian des hommes et des femmes par
tranche d'âge selon le bureau of labor
statistics des états unis c'est des
données de 2010 neuf donc ça colle avec
mon échantillon
et puis après j'ai multiplié ces
montants par le pourcentage de chacune
des tranches d'âge de mon échantillon
pour obtenir les revenus médians totaux
de mon échantillon pour l'échantillon
que nous sommes fabriquer le salaire
médian des hommes s'élèvent à 48 1573
dollars par an et le salaire médian des
femmes s'élève à 39 1743 dollars par an
regardons maintenant comment ces
différences affecte les revenus de mes
deux groupes
je considère donc que dans mes deux
groupes tous les hommes gagnent 40 8160
dollars et que toutes les femmes gagnent
ils 39000 743 $ et le niveau de revenu
moyen pour chacun des groupes et donc
roulement de tambours de 45000 257 $
pour le groupe défi fou du biniou et de
41 1970 dollars pour le groupe des
baffes il faut du biniou alors faisons
une petite pause déjà on remarque que
mes estimations sont en dessous des
leurs de l'ordre de 2000 $ pour chaque
groupe
c'est pas forcément étonnant du fait de
toutes les approximations qu'on a dû
faire il suffit que dans leurs
échantillons il est un biais de
sélection qui ferait qu ils ont
davantage de personnes diplômées et ça
ferait mécaniquement monter leurs
revenus
mais ce qui nous intéresse davantage
c'est l'ordre de grandeur de l'écart
entre les deux niveaux de salaires que
j'obtiens ce que je peux conclure ici
c'est que d'après ce que c'est de la
composition sexuelle des groupes
si l'échantillon représentatif de la
population on devrait avoir un écart de
salaire de 3000 287 $ entre les deux
groupes qui ne s'explique que par la
différence de sexe
on est donc bien dans l'ordre de
grandeur des 3000 $ donc autant dire
qu'avec leur écart initiale de 3000 $
ils sont bien loin de pouvoir dire que
le fait de se chatouiller la machine à
fantasmes et puis jouer un quelconque
rôle dans le niveau des salaires et la
différence de composition sexuelle des
groupes et bien une variable suffisante
pour expliquer la totalité de la
variation mais quelle surprise
alors là vraiment j'en tombe des nues
allez maintenant c'est le moment d'une
petite conclusion pour conclure d'abord
un petit point méthodologique simplement
pour vous dire que tous les calculs
lequel je me suis essayée là c'est pas
du travail vraiment scientifique un
simplement parce que n'ayant pas accès à
leurs données j'ai dû les reconstruire à
grand renfort d'approximations en
réalité quand on a un jeu de données
comme ça on utilise ce qu'on appelle des
variables de contrôle pour éliminer les
facteurs de confusion
par exemple ici j'aurais tester la
valeur explicative de ma variable prise
en main on la contrôle en parme variable
sexe ce qui m'aurait permis d'étudier
les choses toutes choses égales par
ailleurs ou du moins tous sexes égales
par ailleurs
et si dans le groupe des hommes ce qui
se tirent souvent sur la nouille gagnent
plus que les autres et même chose chez
les femmes
là on aurait pu commencer à mettre en
évidence une corrélation qui n'est pas
influencée par la composition sexuelle
des groupes mais cela dit
après les apprentis mais ce que j'ai
fait je doute que cette corrélation
existe et c'est à mon avis pour ça
qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait et après pour
les variables de contrôle on n'était pas
obligé de mettre que le sexe ne pouvait
mettre autant de variables qu'on juge
pertinentes pour essayer de neutraliser
les effets des facteurs de confusion
même si évidemment de fait on peut
jamais les maîtres tout où on ne peut
pas les multiplier indéfiniment
bon maintenant que ça c'est dit vous
aurez compris que j'ai principalement
utilisé cette étude comme un prétexte
pour vous parler de corrélation une
causalité en réalité unis via le fameux
organisme qui a réalisé l'étude
c'est par laboratoire scientifique c'est
une marque qui a pour but de vous vendre
des produits sains de la crème des
tonifiant des marchés comme ça ça arrive
souvent que les laboratoires se lance
dans ce genre d'étude et ça explique
sûrement le manque de scientificité des
résultats mais ce que je voulais
souligner ce n'était pas tant le manque
de scientificité de l'article que la
façon que les journalistes ont eu de
communiquer autour de ces résultats
parce que la plupart des journalistes
n'étaient pas dupes sur le caractère peu
scientifique des résultats mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'ils se sont quand même
contenté de faire un copier-coller des
résultats sans vraiment montrer en quoi
ces résultats étaient problématiques du
coup si vous voulez retenir une chose de
cette vidéo c'est fait attention quand
vous voyez passer une article qui
commence par le fameux une étude
américaine dit que et accessoirement
retenez aussi que ben non un
actuellement rien ne nous permet de
conclure à un quelconque effet de la
thur l'upnet sur le type et le niveau de
rémunération dans l'emploi donc m'a
évité de mentionner vos habitudes
autosatisfaction sur un cv ça pourrait
être mal interprété
en revanche même si cela n'a aucun effet
sur les salaires les études tendent à
montrer que prendre soin de son intimité
est associé à une image plus positive
est confiante de soi même et que cela
produit des biens faits en termes de
détente et de réduction du stress donc
ne vous retenez pas pour autant et à ce
propos j'en profite pour mettre un petit
coup de projecteur à un projet que je
trouve super sympa c'est pas une vidéo
sponsoriser un je gagnerai dans la
sphère j'ai juste envie d'aider à faire
connaître le travail d'un couple d'amis
qui sont en train de se lancer dans la
manufacture de sextoys inspiré de monde
féerique et héroïque fantaisiste ferrat
dimon c'est le nom du projet lancé par
margot et romain qui ont eu l'idée de
mélanger sextoys et fantastique
les sextoys sont réalisées grâce à une
imprimante 3d en silicone qui est une
matière call avantage d'être durable et
biocompatible ça veut dire que tu peux
la mettre à l'intérieur de toi il n'y a
pas de risque il y aura différents types
design différentes tailles 3° de
rigidité et plus d'une quinzaine de
couleurs de sorte que chacun pourra
vraiment commandé un objet ultra
personnalisés j'en parle au futur parce
qu'ils sont encore à la phase des
prototypes et les produits ne sont pas
encore disponibles à la vente
en plus avec le confinement c'est un
petit peu difficile de s'approvisionner
en silicone cependant je vous invite
quand même allé les rejoindre sur
facebook et sur instagram parce qu'ils
sont en train de développer tout un
univers fantastique autour des sextoys
le monde de ferrat qui est peuplé de
toute une faune extraordinaire est
fantastique et qui vise à créer un
univers culturel autour de la sexualité
je vous invite donc à les suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux ne serait ce que pour
suivre les illustrations de margaux qui
sont plus magnifiques les unes que les
autres et aussi pour l'histoire qui est
en train de se développer petit à petit
après un mystérieux effondrement ayant
provoqué une extinction massive de la
biodiversité la vie a failli s'éteindre
sur ferrat plusieurs millions d'années
plus tard la faune et la flore sont
progressivement redevenu luxuriante et
diversifiée ce constat est à l'origine
de la fondation de la guilde des vériste
une communauté de chercheurs désireux de
comprendre et de protéger le vivant ils
s'organisent ensemble autour d'un projet
commun celui de répertorier et
catégoriser l'ensemble des espèces
animales et végétales dans une
encyclopédie du monde vivant l'histoire
est racontée à travers le personnage
d'aleri nellis elle m'aide à une elfe
rousse apprenti ébéniste
voilà j'espère que ça voudra
suffisamment intrigué pour que vous
alliez jeter un coup d'oeil moi j'aime
bien aussi bien l'idée de mêler sextoys
et fantaisie que aussi l'idée d'avoir un
objet qu'on puisse poser sur son étagère
sans que ça fasse bizarre voilà cet
épisode hors série est maintenant
terminée j'espère qu'il vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre des pousse vers
le haut a partagé m un like à vous
abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà
fait je vous mets en description tout un
tas de sources et notamment des vidéos
pour aller plus loin sur ces notions de
corrélation et causalité parce que je
suis loin d'être le seul en avoir parlé
sur youtube
je vous recommande tout particulièrement
les vidéos de la tronche en biais et de
risques alpha pour tout ce qui est des
questions de corrélation causalité biais
cognitifs et c est par ailleurs je vous
mets aussi le lien vers une vidéo de
hacking social pour muscler son esprit
critique notamment pour ses articles qui
reprennent ses études américaines dont
on n'arrive pas vraiment à retrouver la
source et il nous montre le processus
parfois fastidieux qu'il faut
entreprendre pour v
et fier les informations en attendant je
vous fais des bisous de confinement à la
prochaine et restez chez vous ciao
[Musique]